you okay in there chick okay
serena is in a lot of pain her doctor
has sent her to have an mri scan
at holton general hospital four months
ago
it could not have happened holton like
hospitals across the country
was forced to pause all non-emergency
treatments
serena would have had to live with the
pain the hospital to take the
temperature before you come in and it's
all
cleansing and you know um so
i don't i have no fear at all
pre-covered would have been full of
chairs which obviously we've taken out
in june procedures were started at their
covert safe site
staff here have been desperate to see
their patients return
all the additional measures that have
been put in have just been
one more thing because it's so important
to us that
our patients are safe because we want
our patients to come
we want we're here we're open for
business
the hospital is near to seeing the same
number of coveted patients now
as it did during the peak
the difference this time is that they're
continuing
non-coverage every day
pressure grows on the hospital it might
be forced to pause non-emergency
treatments
again we absolutely recognize
the length of time that some patients
have been waiting on those waiting lists
and we will continue through all our
planning
to ensure that we keep those going for
as long as we possibly can
but we do need to be mindful that there
may come
a point where we have to make some
really difficult decisions around those
services
the hospital will battle to stay open
and it has one very important asset on
its side
an on-site lab that can effectively test
all pre-op patients and staff
we expect to see a larger number of
coronavirus patients coming into the
hospital
as well as other patients so we are
committed
to trying to maintain our elective
surgery procedures as much as possible
so the demand on our laboratory is
massive and
it's going to be a challenge to try and
maintain our capacity for to do those
but even an effective testing regime
can't create the capacity needed
if the hospital is overwhelmed some
really really difficult decisions had to
be taken
ahead of the peak of the pandemic to
create extra capacity
in our hospitals but we're only now
beginning to understand the
impact of those decisions on the
nation's health
the patients doctors nurses nobody at
this hospital
wants non-emergency treatments to stop
in the coming days and weeks
we'll know if that's a decision that has
to be made
joshi sky news